what i'm saying quite critically is it
takes two to talk right yeah so the
aliens might be there but if we if we
don't have the ability to recognize them
and talk to them then the aliens aren't
going to want to talk to us and i think
that's the critical point and probably
um if if that is a if that's a filter
there needs to be an ability for one to
communicate with the other and we need
to know what life is before we do that
so we haven't qualified to even join
their club to have a talk well i think
they still want to teach us how to talk
right but
my worry is that
uh or i i think they would want to teach
us how to talk like you do when you meet
it
uh like
when you even meet that i was gonna say
child but that's a human species
i mean like uh and
you want to try to communicate with them
through whatever devices you can given
given what an ant it's like i just i
worry mostly about that humans are just
too close-minded or don't have the right
tools no i'm going to push back on this
quite significantly i would say because
we don't understand what life is and
because we don't understand how life
immersed in the universe we don't
understand the physics
that gave rise to life yeah and
that means our description fundamental
description i'm way out of my pay grade
even further out there better but i'll
say it anyways i think it's gonna get
paid much anyway so as you said earlier
so
so
so i would say that we because we don't
understand the universe yet we do not
understand how the universe spat out
life
and we don't know what life is and then
i think that until we understand that it
is going to limit our ability to even
um we don't qualify to talk to the
aliens
so i'm going to say that the the they
might be there but we just i'm not going
to say that i believe in
interdimensional aliens being present
yeah but i think you're just being
self-critical uh like we don't qualify i
think i think the fact that we don't
qualify qualifies us we're interesting
we're interested in our innocence no i'm
saying that
because we don't understand causal
chains and the way that information is
propagated in the universe and we don't
understand what replication is yet and
we don't understand
um how life emerged i think that we
would not recognize aliens and they and
if if someone doesn't recognize you
you wouldn't go and talk to it you don't
go and talk to ants
you don't go and talk to birds or maybe
some birds you do right because you can
and there's just enough cognition so i'm
saying because we don't have enough
cognac our cognitive abilities are not
yet where they need to be
we probably haven't been communicating
with them so you don't agree with the uh
dating strategy of playing hard to get
because us humans that's going to
attract us within us within the species
that's fine but i think we don't
actually actually have abstraction no i
actually i think you've in in this talk
in this conversation you've helped me
crystallize something that i think has
been troubling me for a long time with
the fermi paradox i'm pretty sure that
a reasonable avenue is to say that you
would not go and talk to
your cat about calculus
right but i would still pet it sure but
i'm not talking about petting a cat the
analogy is that the aliens are not going
to talk to us because we and i'm using
calculus as an analogy for abstraction
because we we lack the um layer the
fundamental layer for understanding what
life is
and what the universe is in our reality
that it's it would be so
counterproductive interacting with
intelligent alien species that it would
cause more angst for the univ for human
race
um they don't care
okay they got to be self-interested so
they'll probably they more care about is
it interesting for them
maybe they
i mean surely there's a way to
to pat the to pet the cat
in this
this analogy because um
even if we lack complete understanding
it must be a very frustrating experience
for
for other kinds of intelligence to
communicate with us still there must be
a way to interact with us well like
perturb the system
in interesting ways to see what these
creatures do we might actually find the
answer i mean again out of my pay grade
in in
in a simulation
of earth or say let's say a simulation
where we allow
an intelligent ai to emerge right and
that and that ai
we then give it
um
the objective is to be curious interact
with other intelligence in its universe
and then we might find
the um the parameters required for that
ai to walk with and i think you'll find
if the the ai will not talk to other ais
that don't share
the ability to abstract the level of the
ai because it's just a cat and would you
are you going to travel 20 light years
to go and pet a cat so not because of
the
inability to do so but because of like
boredom it's it's more interested it
will start talking to it will spend most
it will spend a majority of its time
talking to other ai systems that can at
least somewhat understand it's much more
fun it's a bit like do we know that
plants are conscious well plants aren't
conscious in the way we typically think
but we don't talk to them they could be
right but there's a lot of people on
earth who like gardening there's always
going to be a weird thing they're just
gardening okay well you're not romantic
enough to see gardening as a way of
communication between humans oh okay you
got me
but there is there's ways there's always
going to be the people who are curious
jane goodall who lives with the
uh with the chimps right there's always
going to be curious intelligence species
that visit uh the weird or earth planet
and and try to interact i mean it's it's
uh yeah i i think it's it's a super cool
idea that you're expressing and just to
kind of have a sense maybe it's a hope
that there's always going to be a desire
to interact even with those that don't
can't possibly understand the depth of
what you understand
so i'm with you that look so i want to
be as positive as you that we the aliens
do exist and we will we will interact
with them what i'm trying to do is to
give you a
a reasonable hypothesis why we haven't
yet
yeah and also something to strive for to
be able to do that i mean i you know i
there there is the other view that that
the universe is just too big and life is
just too rare
but i want to make come up with an
alternative explanation which i think is
reasonable and not been philosophically
and scientifically thought out which is
this this
if you can't actually communicate with
the object
the pers the thing
competently you don't even know it's
there yeah then then there's no point
yet
you